vous ne l'avez pas vu tomber c'est très
ennuyeux parce que nous partons tous à
la plage et nous n'avons pas pu le
prévenir
oui tant pis merci au revoir madame est
alors allée sa tante adélaïde ne l'a pas
vu non plus haut on veut c'est vraiment
trop bête ça alors on a laissé des
messages par tous personne n'a pu lui
dire que nous allions la plage qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
bon écoute tant pis on y va on va pas
attendre éternellement
allez les enfants on y voit pas la plage
ap la besace limites qu'est ce que tu
fais là haut je ne peux pas vous
déranger que ce que tu nous racontes
je vois bien que vous voulez aller à la
plage sans moi écoute casimiro tu as
cherché partout
vous m'avez pas vraiment cherché un
sinon vous m'auriez trouvé que tu
vraiment casimir moi je suis désolé que
tu crois des choses pareilles je sais
pas quoi de pire de new york
bon bah écoute casimir on n'a pas fait
tous les efforts qu'il fallait pour te
trouver voilà on te demande pardon
et maintenant viens avec moi la plage
alors tous à la plage non et pourquoi
parce que je ne veux pas pour déranger
en tout cas j'ai vraiment dû commencer à
exagérer mon vieux à wade je dis quelque
chose tu te mets en colère alors bon ben
je suis en colère
là et maintenant explique nous pourquoi
tu crois que tu nous dérange parce que
je suis de trop je vous dérange le goût
de quasi mur tu sais que je t'aime
beaucoup
alors si on a fait une erreur tu nous
l'as dit puis on essaie de la réparer tu
veux bien vous savez très bien que
j'adore faire des châteaux de sable
oui alors qu'est ce qui t'empêche
d'enfer que faut-il pour faire des
châteaux de sable
bah oui il faut il faut se croire en toi
alors que alors emmanuel tu veut bien
prêter tons chauds à casimir pour qu'ils
soient plus triste alors je lui donne
voilà et bien maintenant casimir je vais
passer une tu as tout ce qu'il te faut
pour faire un magnifique château de
sable tu es d'accord
ouais mais c'est quoi qu'est ce qui se
passe encore je vois bien qu'un que vous
m'en voulais d'avoir pris le sceau des
manuels
non que du mur vraiment tu seras tu en
veux pas du tout mais l1
non tu ne veux pas casser mais bon voilà
bien des coteaux on va la place non et
pourquoi
qu'est-ce qu'il va pas encore cette fois
quasi mais tu le sais très bien mais
nous je te promets que j'ignore ce qui
te farges
bon et bien vous n'avez pas remarqué un
ce joli petit vent qui agite les
branches des arbres sains
oui oui bien sûr bon alors que peut-on
faire à la mer quand il y a un joli
petit vent comme aujourd'hui un duel et
voilà qu'à l'aide de virtual eye
personne n'a pensé à ramlé c'est mon
petit foyer préférées
c'est nathalie troquet de livres liée au
retour à elle te le donne un les bonnes
avec toi mais ce sera tout oh oui
alors content ouais bah montre le à
poulies vraiment que tout le monde me
vue de mon casimir nous nous ça nous
rend malheureux de te voir tu ris que tu
sais bon alors voilà
jasmine d'horreur mais content j'ai
envoyé on va à la plage way pour le club
moi non mais attendez un instant qu'il
faut que je prenne mes affaires toutes
mes affaires que j'ai préparé derrière
la reine the fair milk mais venez venez
il faut m'aider qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire
les enfants là n'oubliez pas et des mois
qu'il est un bon ballon et casimir et
des casinos coin n'oubliez pas les
palmes des pâles copies moment du bateau
l ai pris mon argent la boue et le
bateau électrique les palmiers
pourquoi les enfants venus avait sa
douzième bombannes une bouée france 3 ça
y est j'ai tué 13 points ils ont casimir
si je comprends bien tu organiser toute
cette petite comédie sans grande
intéressante qui aurait apporté toutes
les affaires de plage parce que tu
savais très bien que nous y allions - et
alors
et alors et bien malheureusement
aujourd'hui personne lire à la plage
avec tout le temps qui nous a fait
perdre il est beaucoup trop tard bon